♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THAT EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ANTIFA WENT ON THE ATTACK IN
PORTLAND, OREGON, YESTERDAY.
ONE OF THE VICTIMS JOINS US
AHEAD WITH AN ACCOUNT ON WHAT
HAPPENED.
FIRST IT HAS BEEN A BEWILDERING
COUPLE OF MONTHS FOR BILL BARR.
IMAGINE YOU ARE BILL BARR.
VERSE SERVED AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
GEORGE H.W. BUSH, 1991.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAD
JUST TURNED TWO YEARS OLD.
THIS FEBRUARY, PURELY BY PROCESS
OF ELIMINATION, HE BECAME
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES ONCE AGAIN.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
NEARLY OVER WHEN HE GOT THE JOB
AND HE PROBABLY DIDN'T EXPECT TO
BECOME A MAJOR FIGURE IN THE
RUSSIA STORY BECAUSE HE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW HE NEVER MET
WITH SECRET AGENTS AND PRAGUE
CORTEX OF VLADIMIR PUTIN ON HIS
BLACKBERRY.
IF YOU BETRAYED THIS COUNTRY FOR
RUBLES OR A CASE OF VODKA,
NOBODY HAS EVER PROVED IT BUT IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THE RUSSIAN STORY CANNOT DIE.
CNN, "THE WASHINGTON POST," MANY
OTHERS HAVE TOO MUCH INVESTED IN
THAT STORY.
THE FACT THAT HAS BEEN UNTRUE IS
RELEVANCE.
HE IS A HANDY WAY TO KEEP RUSSIA
AND THE NEWS.
WATCH TODAY'S TALKING POINT IN
ACTION.
SOMEWHERE IN THE BASEMENT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE,
SOME CONSULTANT HAS DECIDED THAT
CREDIBILITY IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE LINE OF ATTACK.
WATCH.
>> WE ARE JOINING THE CHORUS OF
DEMOCRATS JOINING HE SHOULD
RESIGN.
WHY?
>> HIS CREDIBILITY WASN'T
SHREDDED YESTERDAY.
>> HIS CREDIBILITY WAS
DESTROYED.
>> THIS ATTORNEY GENERAL LACKS
ALL CREDIBILITY.
>> HE HAS BURNED THROUGH ANY
CREDIBILITY HE HAD IN THAT ROLE
AND HE SHOULD RESIGN.
>> Tucker: WHAT WE HAVE HERE
IS WHAT WE ALWAYS HAVE YOUR
EVERY SINGLE TIME, WE HAVE
PROJECTION.
THEY CALL YOU WHAT THEY
THEMSELVES ARE, WHETHER IT IS
PRIVILEGED OR BIGOTED OR HATEFUL
OR FRAUDULENT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO SPEND TWO
FULL YEARS WITH HYSTERIA OVER A
BOGUS STORY BUT THE REST OF US
THEY TELL US WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE WHO LACK CREDIBILITY.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO HATED
THE RESULTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
ELECTION SO MUCH THAT THEY
DROPPED EVERYTHING AND WORKED
TIRELESSLY FOR YEARS TO NULLIFY
THAT ELECTION.
GUESS WHAT THEY'RE CALLING OTHER
PEOPLE?
ENEMIES OF DEMOCRACY.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JOINED
WITH HIS SUPERVISOR, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DECIDED TO SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS NOT A
DEMOCRACY.
>> STOP THIS ATTACK ON OUR
REPUBLIC AND SAVE THIS NATION,
IT'S DEMOCRACY.
>> IT IS SIMPLY ANOTHER STEP IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GROWING
ATTACK ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS A GRAVE DANGER FOR
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AND A PART OF
THE ATTACK ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: ENGLISH IS THE
LARGEST LANGUAGE IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD, MORE NOUNS, MORE
VERBS THAN ANY LANGUAGE EVER AND
YET NIGHT AFTER NIGHT WE MANAGED
TO FIND TAPE OF PEOPLE SAYING
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
ALMOST LIKE IT'S COORDINATED.
TONIGHT IT IS, THEY ARE
ATTACKING OUR DEMOCRACY SAYS
THEY GUY WHO REFUSES TO WAIT
TILL THE NEXT ELECTION.
IT WENT ON LIKE THIS TODAY AND
ON, DEMOCRATS STOPPED AND TRY TO
MAKE A RATIONAL CASE AND BY THE
END THEY WERE RESORTING TO
PROPER COMEDY.
HERE IS CONGRESSMAN STEVE COHEN
OF MEMPHIS.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT IMAGES OF
YOU WITH WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
BUCKET OF FRIED CHICKEN AND HE
BROUGHT PROPS I SEE.
WHAT DOES THE MESSAGE YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOUND?
>> THE MESSAGE IS THAT BILL BARR
IS A CHECK-IN.
HE WAS A CHICKEN TO COME TO THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND HE
DOES NOT DESERVE RESPECT.
HE HAS LOWER THE BAR FOR LAWYERS
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Tucker: HE DESERVES NO
RESPECT!
HE HAS LOWERED THE BAR SAYS THE
GUY WHO BROUGHT A BUCKET OF